Constanza Romero: I’m Constanza Romero and
I’m here representing my late husband August
Wilson.
He did the film adaptation for FENCES and
he also wrote the original play which played
on Broadway in 1984, 1985 and in 2010 with
Denzel Washington.
Film Courage: Tell us about what you saw in
his (August’s) work ethic and how he would
dive into a story.
How did he create a world on the page?
Constanza Romero: Well his work ethic was
this: to live was to work.
And to work was to live.
He was always working.
He was always developing his characters.
If we say down to eat he, was talking about
his work and his characters were like almost
real, you know?
He would tell me what a character was doing
and I was like “Oh, my God.
He robbed a bank?”
So how he developed it, he wrote in long hand
and then he transferred it to the computer
and then he would always talk in his rhythm.
Until it sounded good in his ear he wouldn’t
finalize it yet because he was all about…his
poetry was his music and if it didn’t sound
right to his ear, he rewrote it and rewrote
it.
And that is where you can see where he was
a poet first.
Film Courage: What can you share with our
viewers about being so close to someone that
is so involved in the creative process and
in some sense you are sharing your life with
another entity and that is their work?
Constanza Romero: Well, I’m a costume designer
so we collaborated on a lot of projects.
I would be sort of his visual dramaturge so
to speak because I would find different photos
that were inspirational to him while they
were inspirational to me too because I was
doing the costumes and he would also say the
lines out loud and I would read his first
scripts and I would say “Well, what about
this character?
Could she be this or could she be that?”
And so the collaboration process was really
incredible.
But sometimes it was a little too much.
As I said, we would be downstairs eating and
he would go on, and on, and on, and on, about
the play and I would just say “Oh!
I’ve got to go to work.”
And he’d follow me up the stairs and eat
a sandwich right by my drawing table….but
it’s all just good memories.
Film Courage: Any of the characters or one
specific character that was most like him
in some sense?
Constanza Romero: Oh….you know…I have
to say that all of the characters are like
him and although the character of Rose is
definitely inspired by his mother.
But I think that this is the amazing breadth
of his work is that all his characters had
little part of himself but they were also
so imaginatively created.
So I can’t say that there is one person.
For example when he was young, he was the
older son whose art nobody understood, you
know?
Because he was writing poetry on napkins and
menus.
So the older son Lyons [in FENCES] he was
sort of like him carrying around his pen and
paper like he carries around his instrument
and playing at night but nobody in his family
understanding why the heck they don’t get
a job.
Right!
Yes!
Film Courage: And lastly, what can you tell
others about what it’s like to share your
life with someone who at some points maybe
they are critical of their own work?
And watching them go through days that maybe
they didn’t feel good about their projects
even though others related to them but it
was such a tough process because they were
so close to the material and couldn’t see
it for what it was?
Constanza Romero: Yeah…August hated to cut.
If somebody said the play is longer than three
hours, what are we going to do?
So I think that he would be so stubborn, nobody
could make him cut something.
And then finally one of the producers set
me aside and said “Can you tell him that
Seven Guitars is a little too long.”
And actually I sat down and I could really
see where it could be snipped here and there
and I was able to help him do that.
But I believe I was one of the only people
he really trusted to tell him the truth as
you’re saying.
And not every day was inspired, not every
day was a joy.
Creating something is not always a joyful
process.
It has a lot of raw emotions and you are practically
weaving gold.
But the raw material is not always the gold
that it becomes later.
Film Courage: Beautiful!
Thank you!